how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and today we have some pretty
big
spider-man no way home news but not just
spider-man no way home news we have news
about the
future franchises of spider-man within
the marvel cinematic universe including
a new spider-man
that is going to be coming to the mcu
today we have another source telling us
that they have heard from their inside
source that spider-man 3
or spider-man no way home is indeed
going to be a spider-verse film
now of course this has been reported and
teased a lot recently but we have yet to
get an official announcement from
sony or marvel although it did look like
we got pretty close to an official
announcement last week on twitter when
the official twitter account tweeted
writing bios today who wants one and the
official account for spider-man no way
home replied
what you got for me and then the
official twitter account replied again
spider-man no way home starring tom
holland zendaya
jacob battle on toby maguire and andrew
garfield only in movie theaters
this christmas now we're still not
really sure what this is about yet
spider-man no way home's twitter account
did not change their bio to what twitter
said but it looks like this was
definitely done
intentionally whether it was a joke or
whether it was for publicity it
definitely seems like this was planned
adding more credit to the spider-verse
reports and rumors but spider-man no way
home is apparently going to do more than
just introduce
the spider-verse it is apparently going
to set up an entirely new franchise in
the marvel cinematic universe for a
brand new spider-man
and this spider-man is a spider-man that
many people have been waiting for
and that is miles morales it was and
is only a matter of time before miles
morales makes his
mcu debut he's a fan favorite spider-man
and after all he was teased in
spider-man homecoming
when his uncle aaron davis aka the
prowler mentioned that he had a nephew
the other night you told that dude if
you're gonna shoot somebody shoot me
it's pretty ballsy i don't want those
weapons in this neighborhood i got a
nephew who live here
this setup in spider-man homecoming
means that miles morales already exist
within the mcu and we were wondering
when that was going to come full circle
when they were going to
actually introduce him as a character
and apparently miles's future is big
and marvel has some big plans for him to
join the young avengers in the near
future with some other new
young heroes as well however adding
miles morales doesn't mean that tom
holland
is going anywhere despite him saying
that he's taken a break
after spider-man no way home but in fact
according to this report
marvel and sony still have big plans for
him and they plan to use him in a way
that we've never seen him before and
that is to see
spider-man in college but don't worry
i'll break down everything you need to
know about this new report in this video
and if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest
spider-man no way home news so this
report that spider-man is going to be
split into two different franchises
peter parker and miles morales is coming
from
that show.com and they start this
article off by mentioning a very good
point stating that it's an interesting
predicament that marvel and sony find
themselves in
spider-man homecoming made over 880
million dollars and spider-man far from
home
made over 1 billion the first spider-man
film to ever do so
and it's safe to assume that a movie
also starring tobey maguire and andrew
garfield could easily crack
at least 1.5 billion which is a cash cow
that marvel and sony aren't going to
want to walk away from
however you have the current actor tom
holland who is kind of aging out of the
role
almost being 25 in real life and you
also have director john watts who is
being shifted over to direct the
fantastic four
and according to kevin feige on the
investor day presentation they have
already begun to start working on the
fantastic four this means scripting and
filming will happen
relatively soon which means that john
watts is going to be tied up for let's
say
two to four years and perhaps maybe even
longer than that
so according to that hashtag show.com
when sony and marvel
disney entered those renegotiations a
while back that scared us all
having us thinking that spider-man might
not actually be a part of the mcu
anymore
apparently in these negotiations they
wanted to future proof
spider-man which is part of the reason
that they are going to do the
spider-verse
but according to that hashtag show.com
they have exclusively learned that sony
will continue making their
sp umc films or the sony pictures
universe of
marvel characters with marvel continuing
with spider-man as well
that means splitting the franchise in
two and this is what the hashtag show
says that they've heard about it they're
going to create two different franchises
one's going to be peter parker's story
and explore a storyline with him in
college or university
the other franchise is going to focus on
miles morales and it's said that marvel
is keen to use miles on their upcoming
young avengers project and they see a
lot of value in him which of course
who wouldn't he's an awesome character
and a fan favorite and there's a lot of
hype around the young avengers right now
especially if you consider that we just
got billy and tommy or
wiccan and speed in one division not to
mention kate bishop coming to the mcu
along with miss marvel and
other young heroes as well so it's all
kind of coming together here and miles
is a younger spider-man
and this does seem like kind of a
perfect opportunity to bring him in and
possibly have peter parker mentor him
which would also be really good because
a lot of people are kind of tired of
our peter parker having a mentor or a
coach
they want to see him kind of go at it on
his own so it would be really good if he
actually was the mentor himself but
continuing with that
show's report they say that from what
they've heard no way home is going to
provide us a much
clearer road map for spider-man in the
mcu
they want writers and directors who can
bring a distinct voice to each character
and the reason for this according to
this report is because marvel and sony
are concerned about
branding they're worried that having two
spider-man franchises at the same time
will confuse some general audience
members and having a strong vision
behind
each character is their primary strategy
now they do go on to say that there are
vague ideas of how to bring these two
characters together
for some sort of spider-man crossover
but that's years down the line
right now the focus is just on
introducing miles morales to the mcu
which again he kind of already was
because we met his uncle who mentioned
his nephew him
miles confirming that he does already
exist in the mcu
the focus now is going to be on his
introduction and it looks like that is
going to take place at some point
in some way during spider-man no way
home which makes sense now like i
mentioned in the beginning tom holland
said that he's going to be
taking a break now this does not mean
that he is done playing spider-man he
already said if they want him back he is
100 going to be there and as we know
of course they want him back a lot of
people really really love tom holland as
spider-man and there's no doubt that
he's been super super successful with
the character so he's definitely coming
back even though it is quite interesting
that john watts is now going to direct
the fantastic four
and in spider-man homecoming we had some
pretty big easter eggs for the fantastic
four
one of course is there is now a new
owner of what was once the old avengers
tower
now some people thought that this could
be ozcorp but
a lot of people think it's the fantastic
four baxter building in fact a sony
owned tony revolori
instagram account once teased the baxter
building in one of their stories and we
know that marvel sets up things
years and years in advance so unless
this is a huge coincidence it looks like
this building
is going to be the baxter building and
the introduction of the fantastic four
because john watts who directed
spider-man homecoming and far from home
is now going to be directing the
fantastic four not to mention that in
front of the building there's a sign
that says
we can't wait to show you what comes
next along with the numbers
one two three question mark implying
that
four is next or the fantastic four so
hopefully in the future there's some
sort of fantastic four
and spider-man team up but in the
meantime it looks like we have miles
morales to look forward to
coming to the mcu in the near future so
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest spider-man and
miles morales news and let me know who
you think would make a good
miles morales who would you like to play
him in the marvel cinematic universe
leave your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof